these used to be reindeer pastures till
the gas to power whole continents was
found beneath the ancestral homelands of
the indigenous communities we live here
and gas giant Gazprom moved in now the
land is covered with the paraphernalia
of big energy Mother Nature has gifted
Russia the largest gas reserves in the
world but it takes being up here to get
a sense of what that means
[Music]
the bhavan ink of a gas field is just
one of several up here on the Yamal
Peninsula 400 kilometers north of the
Arctic Circle and it's the source of gas
for Nord Stream - that's the 9.5 billion
pound pipeline that will bring Russian
gas through the Baltic Sea to Germany
due for completion by the end of this
year an alternative route to the other
major pipelines which go through Ukraine
and Belarus it's controversial and not
just from opponents of fossil fuels who
a few weeks ago put the pipes in Germany
to alternative use I think it's a
horrific thing that's being done where
you are feeding billions and billions of
dollars from Germany primarily and other
countries but primarily from Germany
into the coffers of Russia when we're
trying to do something so that we have
peace in the world but it does mean
cheaper gas for German businesses and
for consumers across Europe and plenty
of it as Europe's gas reserves
diminished as a problem was Russia
nordstrom - says fears that delivery
through Ukraine will stop aren't
justified in 2017 ninety billion cubic
meters have been transported through
Ukraine you not seem to has a capacity
of 55
how could 55 replace 90
Britain gets its curse from the North
Sea and Norway but it does not trust the
Kremlin on nordstrom - the truth is that
if you want gas from Russia to get to
Western Europe the existing pipelines
exist and it's not a problem what North
stream to does is it salami slices NATO
by cutting some of the Eastern European
countries away from the Western ones and
particularly Germany the u.s. is
threatening to sanction the project and
through the political lens nordstrom -
and the first Nord Stream pipeline don't
polish up well but just as Europe is
trying to diversify its energy mix and
wean itself off Russian gas so Russia is
diversifying its customer base building
a pipeline to Turkey and one all the way
through Siberia to China when you have
this much to play with you might as well
have options dynamically skynews at the
Bhavan ncover gas field in Russia